michael i had to retire the sticks as
you know when you brought me out of
retirement
uh to do this here program yeah i got
you glad i did
you know a little little madden little
madden fix for you that uh welcome to
the 99 club
long overdue but russell wilson is now a
99 overall
rating uh on madden previously only
patrick mahomes was a 99 quarterback i
think russell was in 97
but 19 touchdown passing in 1500 yards
and an undefeated record we'll get you
there
i knew you i knew that was the way to
get dr jason johnson in the movie
nothing he ever needs to
not that you ever need energy you must
be you i know you on cloud nine because
you get an extra week to enjoy being
undefeated your seahawks are on a buy so
you get to
sit on 5-0 for a second how you feeling
yes
i'm feeling great i'm feeling great i
mean like it's a heart attack every week
they for some reason seem to come up
with one halfway decent stop
i think they have had i think look i
think the seahawks defense has produced
more turnovers
than like punts so far this season in
five games but it doesn't matter
we're 5-0 we're gonna come back we're
gonna spank the cardinals i'm not
worried until we face the rams
i never want to call for anybody being
fired especially not a black coach
they probably need to do something about
ken norton jr but as long as russ is
playing the way he is
the only team i'm concerned about in the
entire nfc is aaron rodgers and the
packers
if we have to go play in green bay as
opposed to
coming to seattle look at you man you're
getting ahead of you
like you are so far ahead of yourself
this is crazy hey i gotta i gotta know
though before russell cause you're
you're all about russell right now
before him
who was your guy in seattle like i'm
sure you had a player who said okay that
was it dave craig
i'm like who was
very clear i always rooted for teens
with a black coach and a black
quarterback
so the first team i ever loved uh was
was denny green
and randall cunningham with the
minnesota vikings
and then when they fell apart i became
an eagles fan in like 99 and i rode
mcnabb for 14 years
and then right around the time that the
eagles got rid of mcnabb i was like i
gotta find another team with a black
quarterback and i was literally deciding
between the seahawks
and the 49ers with kaepernick and i
picked the seahawks in russell wilson's
rookie year and that's turned out to be
good for me
oh my god you're a nomad fail you would
take an academic professor
morgan you take an academic approach to
selecting a team i love it
i'm thinking you had roots in seattle
you know where did this come from i mean
you know like so
that makes up but so okay let's keep
talking about your your team for the
time being until rush retires and then
you gotta go find justin field's team or
somebody exactly
but the sun probably is what i'll be
rooting for
let's talk about this 22 year old
monster
averaging 22 yards of catch man dk
metcalf
all right i mean listen i just i
remember when he was coming out and he
was all shredded he was shredded into
julian salad man like
coming out of ole miss he was all rocked
up and whatnot i mean people are talking
about him like he baby t.o
i mean the praise for him is through the
roof man
i mean he's the real deal michael like
last year
megatron look at jamal somebody's
megatron
yeah yeah like last year michael
seahawks fans didn't know
if he was ever gonna be a good route
runner we thought he'd be our sort of
doug baldwin heinz ward possession
receiver
fights you for the ball but doesn't get
much yak right he got all the yak now
i mean he's he's snatching the ball he's
running with it
um you know he made the big sort of
deshawn jackson mistake with losing that
one touchdown
uh about two games ago but but dks
metcalf
is turning out to be the truth and and i
i think right now
and this is not to slam tyler locke i
can't stand when people say there's not
a good receiving core for the seahawks
seahawks have an incredible receiving
court
between dk and tyler metcalf i think
they got a top two or three receiving
corps in the league the only other
people would be close
might be the steelers uh and maybe the
minnesota vikings
and really russell wilson is playing
better than either of those quarterbacks
right now
dk is my next funko pop that's going to
be behind me in my office that's how
good he's playing
okay okay now listen i got to ask you
what
i got to figure out what's going on in
the united states of america but before
i get there
i got to ask you another sports question
i got to ask you about lebron where do
you weigh
in now lebron's got four championships
four finals mvps the whole goat
conversation has come up
where do you weigh in you said you had
you said you had a sermon i saw you
tweeted
the other day you said you had a sermon
ready for us we're ready
i knew lebron was gonna get it done i
knew lebron was going to be the man look
let me i
i don't think people understand the
significance
thank you thank you for showing the
truth i don't think people understand
the significance
of what lebron did and every time he
does something
how it sets the path for everybody else
going into this season
right everybody thought that what lebron
did this year
was going to be accomplished by a guy
eight years younger than him we all
thought this was going to be kawhi
kawhi is going to be the first person to
win a ring on three different squads
mvp on three different squads lebron
does that it's not just that
it's his year 17. he carried a d who
still don't have the heart of a tiger
more like a heart of a kitty cat
he did it after a season
lebron made frank vogel into a
functional coach
lebron took uh uh you know he took
dwight howard who had been a mess for
the last five seasons
he took rondo who couldn't seem to get
along with anybody and turn them into
quality off the bench championship level
players
this man is the pat riley on the court
he brings together
any team accomplishes anything makes
them his acolytes
his disciples and brings home the goal
i will never get caught into any of
these conversations about the goat
lebron is the most important player
in the history of the nba if you look at
what he's accomplished this year
on and off the court oh pastor look you
know when you're in church
every night in the pastor will say
something that you'll make you kind of
look at the at the person next to you
like did he just say that okay wait
right where do we start with this first
of all i'm surprised you didn't say he
turned water in the wine
you act like these
like they touched him on lebron's
garment and all of a sudden they would
transform michael holly
i mean come on man like we all love the
bride but come on now
y'all preaching now both of y'all
[Music]
he's the most you've said two eye words
you said he's the most important
and most influential player of all time
pastor please elaborate
so so here's the thing michael jordan
was the best and the most dominant
i don't think you can take away
essentially six years
of run elite and just being so much
better than anybody else there was no
one
you could ever argue was remotely close
to michael jordan and it's not like he
was playing against a bunch of scrubs
right i mean he was playing against
reggie miller he was playing against
uh you know sort of early he played
against some great players but lebron
if you look at what he's done to
contracts if you look at what he's done
to mobility
if you look at what he's done to player
influence if you look at what he's done
for player empowerment if you look at
what he's done for player politics
there is no player in the history of the
nba who's done all that
michael jordan showed you how to make
money if you happen to be michael jordan
lebron james has shown you you can be
like me
you could never be like mike you
couldn't have the skills like you have a
coach like mike lebron said you can be
like me on any team if you're willing to
work your contract a different way
work your social media a different way
and take your influence from squad to
squad when it suits you
not just with a suits management there's
never been anybody who's done that and
this guy
just feeds everybody hey man take the
take this take that look i didn't
remember what you're gonna say
you got donations like i i i got
that was something i got i got something
i got something that doesn't make noise
none of those coins okay we got we got
some bills going in there but listen
take the transcript of what you just
said you got the prologue right there to
the book
it's i mean you already got it come on
doc i mean
look i buy it though i buy it okay this
is what i that's what i need to know
you said oh it sounds great sounds great
everything's just
gonna argue with it it's hard to argue
this is what it comes down
to you've got one pick you got one pick
to make you're starting the franchise
are you going with jordan are you going
with lebron
oh that's easy that's always lebron it's
always lebron
lebron lebron is is he is
a foundation piece um because he's a
positionless player
if if i start with lebron i got a point
guard
i got a power forward i got a small
forward i have a three-point skill
player if you count lebron
say past 2013 i have my team leader
already
if you give me peak lebron
versus pete jordan right let's say pete
jordan is 96
peak lebron is 2012 2013 i would always
start my franchise at peak lebron
lebron can turn mediocre players into
hall of famers
would anybody have cared about uh stat
stuff and kevin love if it weren't for
lebron
no lebron made deli look good lebron
made kyrie look good
jordan ain't 96. that's not pete jordan
let's let's just let's that's best fixed
92 jordan
they're 92. say it's 92. at least 90
like 92 like okay come on now let's
let's let's get a massive respect
secondly when you start this one gets on
my nerves with people like you can you
can celebrate lebron
it's all around brilliance and how
unselfish he is don't act like michael
jordan didn't make his teammates better
even if it required him punching him in
the face he made people better
lebron was an ex i mean michael jordan
was an exceptional all-around player i
keep saying this all-around greatness
gets underrated because people like you
dr jason johnson
you all want to reduce his brilliance to
his scoring as if that's
all he did he might have done it better
than anybody ever played the game but
that ain't all he did now come on
that's sack religious
here's the thing here's the thing jordan
was an amazing like i said i still think
that one he is the best player but if
you look at how he
if you look at what lebron is able to do
jordan made other players better because
he sucked up so much of the defense
and he sucked up so much of the
attention of the opposing uh
coaching staff that other people got to
flourish
but it's not because he necessarily
trained them it's not because he taught
them how to play the game
it's not because he was distributing the
ball the best it's because he
sucked everything up and he was so good
that other people
also didn't take the heat i mean look if
you ask me as a player
who would i rather play with like see
all you know holly asked me as a gm
as a gm as a team president as a coach i
would start with lebron
if you ask me as a player i don't know
that might be a coin flip because as a
player i know with jordan
i'm never going to take any heat i know
we win or lose with him
no one's ever going to be dragging me on
twitter right but with lebron
lebron fails it's his teammates to take
the heat
hold on mike hold on mike because see
i'm sorry and i i know we got it listen
i know you know listen i know dr jason
johnson morgan state professor msnbc
contributor we're supposed to be talking
about
you know supreme court nominee here is
but hold on we gotta have a beating in
the pastor's office about this hold on
and another thing
i hear you about the influential part i
do you're right
from his political activism no argument
there
empowerment when it comes to taking his
career in his own hands no argument
there
but there is no lebron there is no kobe
this entire generation of nba players
the nba as we know it is built on
michael jordan the idea of a black
pitch man the idea of a black man being
the face of a corporation
from an advertising and a marketing
standpoint comes from michael jordan so
i know we want to say republicans buy
his shoes too
i got it but let's not act like michael
jordan's influence is still not being
felt today
when it comes to player as entrepreneur
player as
brand it's still being felt today so i
just need to point that out i mean i
don't want to
i'm not questioning your scripture i'm
not questioning your scripture
here's the thing though here's the thing
though jordan did take that to another
level but if you want to talk about
the black man as pitch man we can go
back to oj running through an
airport for hertz we can talk about
kareem
i think it was the british knights
instead of reebok like those things were
being said
but nike nike and jordan was another
level though that's all i'm saying
yeah nike and joe was another he might
not have been the first black pitch man
no absolutely not but nike and jordan
that was a different level when it came
to their marriage to michael jordan
um i just wanted to keep doctor
yeah yeah yeah yeah we can get into that
another time but uh
okay let me ask you about that i gotta
actually cause this is great this is
great you gotta come back another time
because he got storm on his chest don't
think i didn't see that
don't think i didn't see this because
i wanted it
x-men i appreciate that this is this is
his version of like battle rap you know
like he's going to see if you can raise
your game
you know what i mean so look doc i got
to ask you
about these hearings that are going on
right now uh
their hearings in in one sense and then
you know lindsey graham is turning into
like a a campaign
a campaign speech ted cruz is doing his
podcast
uh what what do you make george what do
you make
of of the hearing so far you know it's
funny and i i i tweeted this yesterday i
know lindsey graham
does not believe in socialism but why is
he letting jamie harrison live rent free
of his head
like every single time lindsey graham
asked a question
he talked about how he's being outraged
he's talking about how
he's in danger he's talking about how
the democrats are coming out of him
he has literally used the hearings to
complain about the fact that he could
very likely lose his seat so lindsey
graham
has been a joke ted cruz is is asking
amy coney baird all these ridiculous
personal questions you know what's your
favorite book what's your favorite color
etcetera etcetera
here's here's holly honestly this is the
frustrating thing about it none of it
matters
she's gonna get confirmed she's gonna
get confirmed because there are more
republicans
than democrats in the senate that's it
there's no question about it
the democrats can try to slow the
process and
and they haven't and i think they should
i think if i were the
if i were chuck schumer and the
democrats and said i would just not show
up what difference does it make
i would let them vote in an empty room
and show how ridiculous they're being we
already know
that she's basically you know training
to be offered from a handmaid's fail and
get on the supreme court
but that's what makes the whole thing
frustrating to watch a hearing
where the conclusion is already known uh
and you only just hope that the
democrats can win the senate and reverse
some of this stuff when they get into
office
yeah i was saying that it it what is it
like a sort of time said about 14
uh senate races are competitive and they
need what five
uh five to take the majority so that's
something to root for
is so we don't have to sit through this
kind of madness again
exactly what's fast but but you're right
what's fascinating
is that it's a job interview that she's
already got like she doesn't have to
come clean on where she stands on the
positions because we know she's not
sitting there
if it weren't obvious where she stood on
the affordable care act on real versus
wade
on gay marriage you know we already know
how she's going to come now what's
interesting though jason this is my
not my concern but i think this is all
that really matters because you're right
this is not a process so much as it is a
production
of performance by city republicans right
now so we already know what's happening
here
we know that it's their prerogative to
put somebody on the court
it's the president's prerogative it's
the majority's prerogative to put
somebody on the court
who sees who from a conservative
standpoint sees things
the way they do on these issues the one
outstanding issue though
is this idea of the president
wanting the court to look at the ballots
look at the balance for what exactly
like if he's not going to
you know acquiesce or or concede or
whatever words you want to use when it
comes to the election if he's not going
to go out quietly not going to
adhere to the traditional peaceful
transfer of power and he's going to take
this
take this to the supreme court with six
of his justices on there six republican
conservative justices on there
what exactly are they looking at because
the only voter fraud is being committed
by the gop
what would they be looking at if he
actually took this to the supreme court
so so michael here's the end game and
this is why
if joe biden and senator harris managed
to get themselves in the white house
that is the beginning was going to be
probably a generation long battle
uh to actually clean up our constitution
i've said this with you guys before
our constitution is nothing it's an nfl
contract it's trash
um it's a gentleman's agreement and you
can see it in something like amy coney
barrett
the reality is if i was convicted
right or i was i was convicted of
something but not thrown in jail
i shouldn't get to pick my jury i
shouldn't get to pick my judge
the fact that donald trump got impeached
and is still
able to pick a judge that could
potentially be ruling on his own
behavior
is ridiculous that wouldn't be allowed
for any of us
and the real concern is that if the
republican party
in the 2020 election decides after
november if they decide
hey look uh in michigan let's say
the republican state legislature says we
don't think these 20
000 votes are valid so we don't think
the state goes to joe biden
we're going to pick electors that vote
for trump even though
the majority of the state seems to want
something else and the supreme court
would then eventually have to rule
and if you go by the letter of the law
which is electors from states don't have
to be chosen by the popular vote it's a
suggestion not a requirement
you could literally steal the entire
presidential election
on the electoral college and the supreme
court could rubber stamp it
that's why amy comey barrett is
important that's why she is a problem
because she can help hand this election
to donald trump
by disputing ballots that anybody in
their right mind knows a legitimate
that's why this whole thing is dangerous
that's why it's really important to
people go out and vote by such large
margins hey look it's real
easy to steal 5 000 votes it wasn't
what's the line from die hard
if you steal a hundred thousand dollars
you know they may come looking for you
you steal 100 million
you know they'll find you unless they
think you're already dead you can steal
an election that's 10 000 votes
but if people win these states by 50 and
60 000 it'll be harder for the
republicans to steal it
and harder for them to put it in the
hands of the supreme court and
my goodness michael holla if they if
they're not making it hard for people of
their i mean whether they're cutting
power lines they're
having phony ballot boxes i mean michael
holly can you believe the lengths that
people
are going to to try to steal the
selection michael
mike no is it actually right right sorry
my bad it's just right
right right it just kind of happened but
you know doc
i want to ask you this um i don't know
if you had any opinions
when scalia was alive about his
originalist take he's i'm an originalist
and then you know uh amy coney bear
talking about i'm a textualist i'm an
originalist too
just what's your opinion because i think
this this position
it sounds good on the surface i think it
is fraught with
issues do you have any opinion on
originalists and that whole take
yeah so like when i was in grad school
they call it attitudinal
versus legalism it's basically do you
read the letter of the law or do you
interpret what the law wanted to say
it's all nonsense because we're not
robots right
right like like if the law was just
about reading exactly what the word said
then we wouldn't need judges we would
throw it in a computer and teletran one
would spit it back out and we would know
what they were talking about
right at the end of the day this is all
based on everybody's attitude so when
she says
oh i want to read the constitution for
how it was originally written it was
originally written for a woman like you
to never have this job
okay it was originally written
exactly so so it's an absolute nonsense
disingenuous way to interpret the law
and i want to point this out
about where where bear will really go
once she's on the court we already know
she's against abortion rights
we already know that she's against
worker rights but when you read about
the fact
that this woman ruled in a in a
discrimination
uh suit at a job this man was being
called the n-word by his boss and she
ruled
that that does not create a hostile work
environment right she's raising some
black children
she's a problem complete problem yeah
listen i was born i was i was born at
night but not last night
it is like you know i think i forgot i
think it was
the uh the senator from missouri his
name i forgot watching it today he's
like
there is nothing wrong with having a
christian
pro-life uh woman on the supreme court
it's like
they say it about her beliefs she can
have her beliefs but when she applies
those beliefs
at the expense of somebody else's rights
who doesn't believe what she believes
you know it's just it's in the shame of
it all
you know speaking of amy's amy klobuchar
going in every time she can about it
the shame of it all they shouldn't be
having this conversation and they keep
trying in vain to appeal
to republican sensibilities or sense of
morality
keep saying hey we got people literally
dying
suffering business is closing why are we
ramming through this confirmation when
we should be passing stimulus relief
they're like huh what what what
mitch mcconnell was laughing about that
in his debate with amy mcgrath she was
just today we got 200
000 people who have died of this disease
and folks out there starving losing
homes etc etc
and he's laughing like the crypt keeper
i mean like most of these guys don't
really care
about what's going on in the country
because what they recognize is that if
you have the right justices in place
look at what just happened in texas
right
you got the republican governor abbott
saying that harris county which has two
million voters
two million voters can only have one
drop-off site like i said that's like
saying
every single red box in all of america
has to be delivered to cleveland right
like
it's that ridiculous to say all those
voters have to go to one place
but why was that approved because a
trump appointed judge
said that that's a decision that was
appropriate so this judge thing is real
black folks need to be clear about what
their rights are going
to be under this administration and i
have to say this because it's important
to me
i'm mad at ice cube for saying he gonna
work with donald trump on this platinum
plan
because the more brothers out there who
are naive enough to believe that this
white nationalist cares anything about
you
are black folks that are shooting
themselves in the foot no vagina
right it's called the breath it's not
the platinum plan it's called the
platinum plan
like do we need to like i mean come on
like do you do we need any more evidence
of what this dude is really about
and you know what uh mike and doc
johnson man we might have to quote
ice cube's lyrics to him when he was
trying to clown easy
i never had dinner with the president oh
wait a minute oh hold on
so so now you about to now you're about
to work with me
because that's exactly it that's exactly
he was screaming about bush
25 years ago when he was doing this i
mean it's absolutely ridiculous and
and again michael as you were pointing
out even the name the platinum plan
is sort of lowbrow insulting i mean
might as well call it the good cushion
alcohol healthcare deal
like you think that that's the only
thing that black folk are going to
respond to
you know i mean but but cuban a lot of
these brothers you know they're caught
up by whatever is shining
and getting their money on and look if
ice cube was just a republican
i'm down with it but the real issue is
that ice cube was sitting there saying
for five months
oh you know i don't know what the
democrats have to offer it's right there
in front of you
it's a lift everybody if you like it
great if you don't like it great but
don't say there ain't no plan
since you could go cozy up to donald
trump you know
it's funny uh we ended the show
yesterday michael smith uh got on me
saying man you can't be bringing this up
at 4 50. but i was making dude it was it
was 455.
it was 455. and he wants to go in on
black trunks
at 4. he was 451. no but i but jason i
was not talking about the black
we did in time i was not talking about
black trump supporters i was talking
about the hilarious i don't know if
you've seen the
these ads i know you have of these hey
i wasn't black people i was an obama
voter but now
i'm all like these they're lying jason
they are lying
they're lying they're lying and and here
i will tell you all
you all can probably guess i know black
trump supporters i know black
republicans and i tend to make a
distinction between the two
right i know a lot of brothers and
sisters who are republicans i've worked
with them for years i've known them for
years
but this this ad which runs during nfl
games i saw it like five times
and they keep throwing out all these
black people here's what doesn't work
about this one
we already know from the trump campaign
that they consistently use black faces
that don't even know they're being used
right like they pay people to show up
they use paces and images that aren't
necessarily people who are bringing with
it but here's the other thing
ain't no pastor sitting in the middle of
my seahawks game
gonna convince me that a man was calling
for white nationalists
to attack me at the polls who said that
my people are garbage who says that my
answers are from
[ __ ] countries none of these people
are going to convince anybody to vote
and we have to remember that they're not
trying to get black people to vote for
trump that's the sneaky part
it's not about trying to get black
people to vote for trump it's about
trying to get
black men in particular to say that
there's no difference
between trump and biden and therefore
they will stay home
they don't want our votes they want our
apathy and that's where those
commercials come from because
everything in that ad is an absolute lie
trump ain't brought nobody else out of
jail
everything jeff sessions done everything
william barr has done they've gotten rid
of consent decrees
more black people being shot and killed
every single one of these instances that
we've seen
of black folks being shot abused by
police or vigilantes in the last year
and a half
where's the trump administration been
where's the doj been where have they
been when it comes to bringing
these people to justice they're out
there trying to turn daniel cameron into
the next clarence thomas
and trust me he'll probably put him on
the supreme court if he can once he's
done with his wedding
so let's be clear that donald trump and
all these advertisements
ain't about us it's about his own people
and making us forget our own power
the doors of the church are open because
as the president preacher's grandson i
know not to follow up
a sermon with another servant we gonna
leave that we're gonna
we gotta leave that there and we're
gonna call for offering we're gonna go
to break
jason say bro always a pleasure man
every wednesday
our favorite day of the week